وسعادتي الامن هذا هو السبيل الوحيد
الذي يسمح لنا بيجد ظروف من اجل تحسين
الامن وكذلك
يتراجع فيه الخوف خلال الاجتماع
الاسرائيليه وصلت الفلسطينيه وشركائنا في
القاهره سمعت قلقا كبير النساء المسار
الراهن سمعت ايضا افكار العزيز
اذا كانت لدى الاطراف الرغبه في ذلك الوقت
المتحده دائما جاهزه ورغبه في خدمه السلم
والامن لدى عوده الى الوطن في الايام
المقبله ساواصل الاشراك من يتشاجرون
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه العمل
الحريه والامن والفرس والامن والكرامه
بنفس المستوى
الرئيس
الضفه الغربيه
التي تقدمه
فرص متساويه للاسرائيليين والفلسطينيه هذا
يشمل للبناء على الجهود التي بدلناها خلال
العامين الماضيين بطرق ملموسه من خلال لقد
اعززنا دعمنا لوكاله اونروا للاجئين
الفلسطينيين بما في ذلك حوالي 50 مليون
دولار وهو تمويل جديد على اليوتيوب انه
اليوم في رام الله والتعليم
انه المغرب والامارات من خلال الاجتماع
الاول لمجموعه العمل وهذا كان اكبر اجتماع
من نوعه من البلدان العربيه واسرائيل منذ
للمؤتمر مدريد قبل عده عقود بالنسبه لقضاء
الاسيوي مثل الامن الغذائي ومن المياه
والامن الطاقه جهودنا ترميلي
عدم الثقه
اسرائيل ووصلوا التعامل مع
التهديدات المشتركه بحث
لاعمال النظام الايراني
بروسيا نحن نرى هذه من القضايا التي تجعل
من الضروري دعم
لاوكرانيا العسكري والانساني والامني
للدفاع عن الشعب الاوكراني ضد حرب روسيا
العوانيه بحثنا سبل من اجل تعزيز الامن
همم بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل كما
فعلت لمس مع رئيس الوزراء
اسرائيل
عاما
القاده المجتمعات المدنيه
العمل الحيوي الذي يؤدي الى تحسين الحياه
وسمعته ايضا من الشباب الاسرائيليين العرب
من اجل الدفاع عن حقوق مثليين لو في هذه
المنطقه لبناء الروابط بين المجتمعات
هذه الاجتماعات تذكرتنا بان المجتمع
المدني في بلدينا يلعب دورا لمناصه منه
للدفاع عن حقوق الاشخاص والمبادئ التي هي
في صلب المجتمعات الحره
العاب
الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
هل
توافق على ان اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
وهل تعتقد انه
يمكن له ان يصون
الديمقراطيه بجانب الفلسطيني الفلسطينيون
لا يعلمون الى اين ستمضي او يمضي حل
للدولتين
ولكن تواصلونا الدعوه لتطبيق هذا الهدف
بعد اجتماع كما رئيس عباس هل تعتقد انه هو
الرجل الذي يمكن ان يحل المشكله الراهنه
وكذلك نزع فتيل التوتر
ومكافحه الارهاب هل لك ثقه به و بالسلطه
الفلسطينيه شكرا لكم
الجزء الثاني من سؤاليك
نحن نركز
على ما تقوم به السلطه
يا شعب الفلسطيني وكذلك
للعمل مع اسرائيل بمسؤوليه اول ما قبل كل
شيء على نزع فتيل التوتر او دوامه العنف
الراهنه التوتر
هذا هو
الاول وسمعت من
الفلسطينيين بمن فيهم الرئيس عباس ومن
الاسرائيليين عن افكار بشان المضيء قدما
لذلك طلبت من زملائي البقاء هنا لدعم
الجهود التي تبذل لتهدئه الامور
اذا هذه هي الاولويه الاولى في عملنا اذا
ما نجحت هذه الجهود عند اذن يمكن
ان يقوم الجانبان
خطوات ايجابيه لاعاده بناء ثقه
لمواصله حل للدولتين ولكن اعتقد في الوقت
الراهن التحدي
هنا هو في منطقه ايضا وهذا امر مقلق لهنا
وفي المنطقه وكما قلت الرئيس يظل ملتزما
ومقتنعا باهميه حل الدولتين
ولكن نحن يجب ان نركز اولا على ضمان ان
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
التوتر ويبداون ببناء خطواته ايجابيه في
علاقتهم
اما بالنسبه للجزء الاول من سؤالك اعتقد
انك سمعتيني اتطرق الى هذا الامر بالامس
العلاقه التي توجد
مصلحه مشتركه
حقوق الانسان
الحره وكذلك المجتمع الحر
المسؤولين المجتمع المدني اليوم والامان
ان يكون لدي اسرائيل مع همم مدني قوي رايت
ذلك بالامس واليوم ايضا طلعت ذلك خلال
الاجتماعات اما بالنسبه
للتعديلات او الاصلاحات المقترح هناك
النقاش حيوي يتم بهذا الشان في اسرائيل
وهذه النقاشه
حي اللي الديمقراطيه الحيه
ان يتم تبني هذه الخيارات وان تكون هذه
الخيارات المستخدمه لكل ذلك طبعا يعود
للاسرائيليين ان يقوم به ونحن
بالشكل العالي
والقيام التي هي في صلب هذه العلاقه التي
استمر 75 عاما
شكرا السيد الوزير
بالاصلاحات تشريعيه وزراء بمن فيها
وزير قال بالامس انه ليس هناك هم ليسوا
بحاجه لدرس في الديمقراطيه ما تعليقكم على
التصريحات من هذا القبيل ثم هل حصلتم على
اي ضمانات من نتنياهو تنفيذ هذه الخطه
سؤال اخر يتعلق به
التصعيد بعد الهجن الهجومين
همم الارهابيين اتخذ قرار بزياده العمليات
الاستيطان هل تعتقدون بان هذا سيؤدي الى
المزيد من التصعيد
هناك مسالتان
يعكس القيام المشتركه التي تجمع الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل وهذا استمر لاكثر من 75
عاما
وهذا ليس ليس اقل او اكثر من ذلك
ووصلوا او اجد دائما مصدرا للالهام في
الحيويه التي
تتسم بها اسرائيل في تشاطر هذه القيم وهذا
ما نراه الان واستطيع ان نقول ذلك عن بلدي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اما بالنسبه للثاني من سؤالك
لقد كنا واضحين ومتفقين
قناه
لا يستطيع
خطوه احاديه
افاق تحقيق حل للدولتين ابعد مما هو عليه
الان
شكرا جزيلا
اريد ان اسالك عن لقائك مع رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو
هل تطرقتم الى مساله ايران
والخطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
[موسيقى]
لصنع القنبله النوويه
انجليزي انجليزي
لايران
مشترك اولا
على الاطلاق القنبله النوويه
[موسيقى]
واليوم خارجها ايضا من هذه الانشطه التي
تحدثنا عنها كان تقديم ايران لروسيا
مسيرات وتكنولوجيا لاستخدامها في عدوان
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
وكما اسلفت من قبل وهذا ما ناقشنا
الاسرائيليين طبعا هذه تاريخ
ايران لا تسلموا الاسلحه في روسيا فقط
ولكن حقيقي